hello folks and welcome to rational
science
i'm back in frankfort had a great time
in south america
uh but big headaches with uh
the bureaucracy all this stuff about
kovid
they don't have good programmers and not
all those online forms work
that's a big headache believe me too
long too lengthy to explain
anyways uh yesterday we had a um
another anniversary of jfk's
assassination
and we have mr oliver stone and he's got
a new movie it's called
um jfk revisited
okay
and
some people are up in arms against this
movie
okay because
it destroys their notion of a land
that's had over 200 years of democracy
and so they don't like movies like this
that uh you know put in question what
the us government the politicians
actually do essentially uh
if it's anywhere like the first movie
jfk
they're saying that the us government
did the elements of the u.s government
did jfk okay did the assassination
wasn't the cues the russians
the mafia well the mafia participated
but it was all run really from
washington dc some higher ups i'll give
you my five cents worth i've researched
the subject for a long time so
um somewhat of an expert i consider
myself someone of an expert okay
and off the top of my head today i said
well let's see if i can list some things
that are patently obvious
about kennedy's
murder that shows that the us government
did it or that at least that it's uh
different than the story they tell the
public right
and this is off the top of my head this
was just kind of brainstorming things
that popped up that i'm saying these are
obvious okay
uh the car was refurbished immediately
they had to destroy that evidence
and so it was taken out
to detroit and uh
you know all the evidence was cleaned up
especially you know broken glass at the
front where a bullet had hit
and things of that nature
and then uh wholesale murder of of so
many people
especially key witnesses
uh oswald himself
even though
my choice if i were to say i think the
smoking gun would be there uh mourinho
he he was oswald's handler for the cia
like the middleman
uh he wrote to george bush father right
saying uh you know i'm being hounded by
the fbi by some agents out there
and he was worried about his life and of
course he ended up being murdered i'm
sorry suicided
he
i think he shot himself like 10 times in
the head you know like like with a
shotgun on his left hand that sort of
thing
and uh
the us government today holds that it
was a different george bush at the cia
to whom moore and shield wrote
to but it doesn't really matter because
if martin shield was
working with or for the
cia
if he was in some way
connected to the cia and he was handling
uh oswald then uh i'm sure that you know
we can
establish
in other words it's the u.s government
who had to show that they had nothing to
do with it they have to prove
that they had nothing to do with it not
the other way around you have to prove
that the us government is guilty right
there's enough circumstantial evidence
to show that oswald was being handled
and then all these other people you know
giancana roselli they went and they
never got to testify
in case of rosella he ended up at the
bottom of the ocean with you know
a bunch of cement on his shoes
and
pitzer you know he's a guy who took
pictures over there at bethesda and so
on well a lot of these people you know
they they were all murdered okay wallace
who was uh
johnson's hit uh henchman he killed
several people interesting you know that
johnson as soon as he became governor
first thing he did was pardon
wallace and got him out of prison after
wallace did the job for him
that's the way the mafia works anyway
lee gets his citizenship the next day
after coming to the states
[Laughter]
yeah sure uh what is that
alice in wonderland or what i have my
friend dave and he relinquished his uh
citizens u.s citizenship
i'm wondering if he can get his
citizenship back tomorrow morning
in fact he went to get a visa to go back
to the u.s to visit i think his family
or whatever and they deny them of course
i mean you know but
lee got it back the next day
yeah that's that's
that is uh you know uh
some place
outside the earth okay not here on on
earth
alvarez and louise uh alvarez feynman uh
saying that you know
the uh kennedy's head actually
ricocheted because the bullet came from
behind
and you know here's the shot here's the
key shot okay
okay you can see it let me put this up
here
there we go you can see it uh that shot
supposedly came from behind
yeah sure uh
again only in wonderland and of course
you got the magic bullet right
so uh that went through 10 places at
once you know
yeah those are the things make you kind
of wonder you know
uh they confiscated cameras the fruit or
film has some missing uh frames
especially when the car turns the corner
okay all those films all those uh frames
are missing
uh
then you have malcolm walls again they
say his
there's a debate on that uh but
obviously the u.s government's going to
take the position that his fingerprints
were not on the sixth
floor of the book depository
and that's what apparently someone found
okay and that's
a big debate there uh then you have
ruby's confession you know uh
jack uh when he was in prison they
questioned him the reporters questioned
him at a given point in time and again
all these videos are wiped out from
youtube and so on so that people don't
see them but ruby said you know the
people who put me in this position
i thought he acted alone i thought he
was a lone gunman and he has the people
who put me in this position and when i
asked him uh who was he
referring to he says
well look at the man at the top
and who was he referring to well johnson
obviously and yeah then you have the
autopsy and the fact that they uh they
didn't do it uh over there in parkland
in texas
they took the body out where they could
the navy could control
all the uh
investigation to the body and so on so
so there's more than enough evidence so
my take you know is who who did all this
uh well it was johnson obviously uh
we have j edgar hoover who
he raised a lot of data and did all the
killings uh with his boyfriend there
clyde tolson who was
the vice president of the cia at the
time uh i'm sorry of the fbi and then
obviously alan dulles who was fired by
jfk
from the cia and uh
ended up in the warren commission
so yeah i mean you got to be quite
gullible to believe that jfk was done by
the harvey oswald okay probably the last
guy who had anything to do with it not
that oswald did not know or maybe was
not involved i'm not saying that he was
completely innocent he was onto
something or into something
exactly what he was into will never know
okay there's only opinions out there but
there's enough hard facts out there for
anyone who looks at this case looks at
it deeply to realize that
this was done by the us government
and to think that the u.s government
would not do such things that's where
people have a big problem they say no no
you know it can't be
and it's uh like hitler said you know uh
the bigger the lie the more people are
willing to believe it you know and i
think that's quite true in many ways
and today uh you know we have this
fellow his name is ting tim
weiner okay
i think that's how he pronounces his
name
and he he takes objection at uh
oliver stone and tries to debase
everything that
stone says in that movie says this is
where oliver stone got his looney jfk
conspiracies from
uh
turns out that when i was on the run
from the fbi you know uh this all
contacted me
and we had a talk
okay he kind of interviewed me over the
phone
and
i realized immediately that this fall
was working on behalf of the cia
you know i had immediate suspicions
about him
and um
yeah people like him are necessary for
the cia you know you have to remember
that the cia will not tell you or the
fbi they will not tell you things that
they're doing especially in relation to
counter-espionage or that sort of thing
yeah they're not going to tell you
anything about that but there are things
that they want the public to know
you know they want to get their voice
across to the public somehow but they
can't go in you know with a microphone
in front of the tv cameras and say look
i'm a cia agent this is what i got to
say and then they tell you a lot of
stuff secret stuff you know they don't
do those kinds of things not the way
they operate and so they have to have
people within the uh
journalists you know
within journalism uh the news world
the fourth power they need people there
uh through whom to ch through whom they
channel
information to the public
why because if this guy says look i
heard from
from cia i heard it uh over there you
know in the
grapevine or whatever i heard all this
information and the guy
put something out
people are more willing to believe that
than if the cia goes out there tells you
directly okay so they use these
uh
reporters
certain ones that they've already
either recruited
or
they have a relation with them doesn't
mean that these people actually work for
the cia or the fbi but they need to
channel information to the public so
that it sounds more realistic to the
public out there than if the cia came
out and said it okay and so uh i think
this uh
uh winer
i call him weiner
he's a weedy uh i think he that's his
job he's been doing that for many years
so if you see him around he's quite
popular out there a little bit hidden
but uh if you look them up you'll find
them and
you'll find that a lot of the
information he puts out
like if he's got an ear inside the cia
it's because the cia uses him
uh voluntarily or non-irrelevant the
point is they do use him to convey
information to the public that's my take
on that and uh you know you have these
two bozos here uh
assange and snowden two u.s government
operations and that's another way that
the uh intelligence agencies found to
get to the u.s public
you know they say look you know what are
these liberals want they want someone
that uh you know complains against the
government okay let's put a leader for
them let's make leaders
that they uh follow
and so people follow these two
individuals thinking they're for real
these people can tell
the public anything they want their
their followers they can tell them
anything they want they'll believe them
because they say look these two poor
fellows are risking their lives look
they left the country and they're being
hounded by the u.s government
yeah that's exactly what they want you
to believe you know that's uh that's how
the the intelligence agencies work i
mean you know the us government spent
spends
uh
over 80 billion dollars a year in
intelligence you say well yeah i mean
they have to spy against china and they
have to spy against russia
now you get it wrong
most of that money is to spy or or to
disinform
the us public that's what that money is
for okay
and uh and these are two fellows that
are in that uh
in that business
this is very simple you know uh
you never
interview them again and nobody hears
about these two individuals period we're
done that's how simple it is
you know if if uh
if these guys are
for real
you just don't interview them you know
you never put them in the news nobody
hears about them ever again
and it's the other way around the united
states does everything possible every
week almost every day you hear about
these two guys
but you don't hear about any of the
whistleblowers
of 9 11.
you won't hear about those at all nobody
even remembers her name i mean april
gallup and
[Applause]
rodriguez
i can't remember his first name you know
these guys nobody hears about them
anymore they're not in the news every
day like these two folks and that's how
you can tell also that it's a us
government operation
so uh you know it's for those people who
want to believe them fine go ahead and
believe them
you know
you you're following two guys that are
being run by the us government that's
all they are i doubt very much that any
of these two guys will ever be
prosecuted
but if they are
the us government could decide at the
last moment
for you know the intelligence agencies
that handle these two fellows they might
decide
to to betray them at the last moment
because governments do that as well they
betray agents if it's in the
national interest so to speak and the
most surprised will be them themselves
you know
they think well i'm in this operation
i'm okay and it turns out the united
states government betrays new agents
that are out there handling them they'll
betray them maybe because of
you know the situation has changed and
now they have to turn them in and turn
them into real people
something that they never expected
that's the way uh the spying business
works
okay uh what's going on in the world
well we have these guys uh
ukrainians
and the united states accuses russia of
amassing uh
troops at the border of ukraine okay
they're saying they're preparing for an
invasion that might even happen as soon
as uh maybe january
and the russians say the opposite it's
the ones who are um you know building up
their forces and causing trouble is the
west
who's right
well i think they're both right that's
what i think i think both sides are
ramping up
okay
and this is just part of the propaganda
campaign you know to get the people
ready you know the public ready for what
might happen
which is a clash
and so the question is uh you know
whether uh
we want this
war to happen
whether this
is the start of world war three
and whether
if if and when it happens right
it's gonna
evolve into nuclear exchanges
hopefully none of that happens hopefully
uh
the politicians
and the diplomats can take care of this
problem but right now you know they've
been rattling their sabers
for quite some time and you know maybe
they're going off to war you know you
have to think about it the military in
times of peace
peace time you know they they have to
prepare for war
otherwise they're irrelevant
okay and uh you know again hitler stalin
all these guys uh give you an idea how
uh you know uh everybody prepared for
war and then war did happen just by
sheer coincidence you know we're
preparing for war it turns out
it all ends up in war now isn't that a
coincidence okay but you know some
people say well it's a good thing that
we have war because first we reduce the
population
and then um you know we get the
industries working again like you know
world war ii especially you know uh
got people back to work they got
the world out of this depression that
was uh
happened throughout the 30s
and today we're in a different world
today we don't depend on manufacturing
so a war is not going to put people to
work
let me repeat that a war is not going to
put people to work we're not alone we're
no longer in the manufacturing age it's
not we're not going to have a war and
produce tons of weapons
that's not going to happen again
okay wars fought differently today
because they have um it's going to be an
internet war
and maybe it's going to be what i showed
the other day where
they knocked satellites out so they not
each other's communications
out
if that happens you know we have no
internet
forget about money because you know all
the money is on the internet
uh all the accounts and so on
so the war is going to be a little
different this time it's not going to be
like in the 30s and 40s
where you know
because of war
women came out of their houses you know
and started working in the factories men
went out to war and got killed and so on
it was a great time you know but that's
not going to happen
you know today it's a push button war
everything's done remote control
so you know and
and the weapons are already on it down
on the ground so it's not like they're
going to need tons and tons of weapons
okay uh in fact uh if you throw a nuke
you know you you can save on a lot of
money which is what the united states
did with japan
in 1945 you know you either go fight
hand to hand a conventional war or you
drop the nukes
guess what truman decided to do well he
decided to drop the nukes
that stopped the war immediately
and of course uh if japan had nukes well
it would have been a great war you know
everybody's slinging uh
nukes at each other right except that
they didn't have that many
okay and uh here's the other
part of the world where we have problems
and this is uh taiwan
and the us warship went through there
this week apparently okay and went
through these taiwan straits
and it says u.s warship again sailed
through the sensitive taiwan strait on
tuesday part of what the us military
calls routine activity but which always
riles china okay there you can see a
little boat
that i put in there
uh
it's like taunting them you know like
putting a chip on the shoulder
and saying i dare you
you know
like uh
you know this these are international
waters
these don't belong to china we can come
here anytime we want
and you know uh
again it's taunting it's
it's like saying i dare you
and not very diplomatic it's uh what
militaries do
when they're very high and they say oh
we're so powerful we're going to get
away with this and we're going to show
them and we're going to rub it in their
nose
but you know those things are the ones
that end up
leading to war because the other side
also has these tough guys
you know and they say oh you're like
that huh wait till we get more weapons
and then you'll see
and so there's this escalation this arms
race
and right now the chinese are catching
up slowly
slowly but surely on the u.s because
they have money and the u.s is having
economic problems more economic problems
than china has at least right
and so you know the united states is
worried about that because the chinese
are developing weapons
and they're catching up and when they
think they're ready
then i'm not sure the ships will be able
to pass through the
taiwan strait again
not that easy at least not without being
bombarded in fact uh putin uh said to
the us that if they keep meddling
in uh ukraine and in the uh
black sea there
you know they're they're crossing a red
line
and he says they're not taking me
seriously
and you don't know something might
happen
someone might pull the trigger
and that starts the whole thing i mean
what did it take for world war one the
killing of uh a prince
and that started the war everybody had
all these packs and treaties and to say
you're on my side right then you're on
my yeah okay and so they all got into a
fight
so that's the way it usually works okay
someone comments on something similar to
this and says our leaders could be
conferencings via holographic means as a
whole on a televised daily regime yeah a
regimen he's right
they could they could all be talking you
know so that we all listen to what they
say
there is no reason they don't
there is a reason they don't okay yeah
the bilderberg group couldn't cut back
uh
uh
door business deals he's saying you know
they're doing all this stuff behind
everybody's back and if you do this out
in the open you know like through zoom
or skype
well it kind of destroys the uh the
secrecy
everybody can tune in and say let's see
what these people talked about
so this gives you an idea that you know
all these uh politicians especially of
the tough countries of the world the
ones that are up there they have to talk
in secret
and a lot of that has to do with their
own public okay they have to be careful
what their own public listens to
so they tell the public one thing
usually through the press or through
people like uh ween earlier
and they uh do something else in private
so you've got to be careful with the
news that you receive because if you
receive the news it's exactly what the
government did not do in the private
session with the other country
there they talk about something else but
the public they have to tell a different
story to the public okay they don't want
to alarm the public of what's going on
or what they're what the citizens
they're taking and those are among the
reasons there are other reasons they
they also talk in secret there are
things that they don't want to mention
to the other side you know each one has
their own cards they're looking at and
they're saying well i'm not going to
show you my ace you know
and so on you know so there's a lot of
that going on but he says uh
it's a this bilderberg meeting is an
annual conference established in 1954
the group's original agenda was to
prevent another world war okay that was
a nice
uh idea on their part okay
it's now defined as bolstering a
consensus around free market western
capitalism and its interests around the
globe specifically it's uh
it's a transatlantic
association
uh all these rich people influential
people they get together and they
discuss things there's some kings and
there's economists politicians a little
bit of everything and they go they have
a little bit of champagne they discuss
things
uh to keep
america friendly to europe essentially
that's what it amounts to but these are
the people who
have lots of influence in the west and
they determine what policies they're
going to take
okay so this is you could say the
illuminati these are the new world order
folks uh the bilderbergs okay
do you really believe presidents of
nations are in any kind of control
uh yeah remember uh politicians in many
ways are puppets of the rich
because if you don't bow down to the
rich you don't get re-elected because
nobody gives you money for your campaign
it's just that simple
and so yeah the politicians pay a lot of
attention to the rich people
and the rich people you know say well
you better kind of you know follow
my recommendation
or i'm going to give the money to
someone else
and so yeah that's the world the way the
world runs okay
i better believe it you know that is the
way the world runs
and so here is a conflict of interest of
few bilderbergers and he shows
uh this link there
and that link is about this okay
uh it turns out that uh you find pfizer
in all these as as a sponsor for all
these um
important news outlets
in fact there are a few more i just put
those you can look up that uh link there
and uh you'll see what i mean pfizer is
behind each one of these and other
programs that
give energy out there that i'm sorry
that
give news out there that provide news to
the public okay and so the question is
does pfizer also have uh influence over
the news as well as over the politicians
okay uh so i don't think about that
and uh here's a last thing the fellow
said the cold war never ended and i i
will agree with that in fact i would say
the cold war never started
because unless you say okay world war ii
ended so that's the hot war and then
the cold war always continues cold war
is preparation for war so cold war is
always interrupted by hot wars when the
war actually takes place but before that
you have this preparation for war all
the time one side is stressful of the
other side very simple you know nothing
out of this world
anyways uh regarding pfizer i've got
some news for you okay you heard it here
first
and here it is
okay
we are going to be sponsored by pfizer
as well
okay here on this channel
if they ever find us
[Laughter]
so yeah
[Laughter]
believe it you heard it here first
okay here's a
another fella makes a comment he says if
this unprecedented historically
explanation
explosion of homosexuality is a fact how
do you explain that it affects
genetically very different groups like
highly inbreeded you know the amish for
example and not so highly like you know
cosmopolitan cities inbreeding
communities at the same time you know so
you have these highly inbreeding groups
because there's a small group like the
amish and then you have you know great
populations that live in the cities
and how does it affect both of them
that's his question which is a a
reasonable question
and all i can tell you is you know what
i think
you know here's a uh just an example
okay of why i think it's uh
homosexuality has to do with
our own evolution and it was unavoidable
because it's in our genes these people
are born that way okay that's my take on
that
doesn't mean that you have to like it or
that you don't like it that's as far as
i'm concerned that's politics that's
opinion this is not an issue of opinion
this is a question
why has homosexuality risen in the last
40 years i mean it's ballooned
and you say well
we're all these people in the closet
always there's maybe 10 15 20
of people who have always been
homosexuals is that what we're saying
here and i'm saying that's not the case
i'm saying that if you go back in time
you'll find fewer and as you come closer
to the present you'll find more and more
i'm saying that more and more people are
becoming
coming out of the wombs with uh
homosexuality in their veins in other
words right
and here's a case uh that
just kind of illustrates that this is
ethiopia okay and it gives you an idea
what's happened
population wise
demographically in especially in the
20th century okay
and this is how their population
exploded
at the beginning of the 20th century
there were about 11 million people in
ethiopia today there's ten times as many
okay
and as the population grew at some point
someone realized that we have oh there
are homosexuals coming out they're
coming out of clusters they're all over
the place
and so they realized that you know more
and more homosexual came out finally in
uh 2004 they put out a law
forbidden for forbidding uh
homosexuality
uh it was already in their culture but
they didn't pay attention to it but they
finally had to put in the books
because it became a problem
and you can see
with this approximately when it became a
problem that they've the heterosexual
community
uh had was forced
to put a law in the books
okay and that was in 2004
and yeah i can more or less relate to
that
in in the sense that you know in the 60s
and 70s you know you never heard about
homosexuality it was a non non-issue
non-topic
and everybody used slurs
very openly it was
no big deal in fact uh you know
especially in south america it was used
constantly you know you you used slurs
against homosexuals all the time
now today that's changed completely you
say what has happened
and you have to remember that what was
in 1973
uh the um
i think one was in 72 nearly 176 one was
the psychiatric association the other
one was
association of the united states of
america
and they declared uh homosexuality to be
they took it out of the
problem of what is it mental problems
see it used to be a mental problem until
that time and after that stop being
categorized officially as a mental
problem
and it's interesting they pulled that
one out but they left some others in
there
they just touched homosexuality
especially relating to men so what had
happened well i'm saying that what had
happened that more and more people
started coming out of the closet
and so they they swamped the offices of
the psychiatrists and psychologists and
then these people say oh what's going on
we had a boom
of homosexuality
and yeah suddenly all these people
started coming out of the closet they
went to psychologists and psychiatrists
say doctor cure me
and what was the psychiatrist going to
do give him a pill or a shot in the arm
you know there was nothing they could do
and say you got to live with it
meaning you know you were born that way
and so they had to take it out because
primarily because of the numbers
i mean i think the
the numbers ballooned
and a lot of these people sought help
there was no help to give them because
you can't do anything about being born
like that
and so they finally had to say well
let's officialize it let's make it
popular let's say it's not a problem
not a problem as long as you're okay
with it no problem then you have no
problem that's essentially what we have
today and so yeah i think the
again that what happened was that
more and more people were born that way
and this was not the case if you go
farther back in time in fact even the
homosexual community says that what
existed in the 19th century was not
homosexuality as they understand it
okay so they say homosexuality the real
one the one they do out there in san
francisco all these other places
it's a lot different than what you would
find if you time travel to the 19th
century
exactly what they mean by that i don't
know but that is their position
and it i also
believe in this that there was a
an evolution that homosexuality was
developed
in other words uh
it came in our veins it was inevitable
it was part of uh
where we were headed and here you see it
it's calhoun's experiments okay this is
uh number 25 this is utopian experiment
and one of the things that i always say
about calhoun's experiments uh on rats
and mice
is that he's one of the first guys to
produce homosexuality in the lab
okay
uh not only did the uh rats and mice
eventually die the uh
colonies became extinct or i think he
terminated them because it was horrible
just to see how they ended up
but the issue is that he called the last
ones the beautiful ones
and the beautiful ones were not only
not interested in sex many of them but
many of them were gay were homosexual
they mounted each other
and so you know uh that's all i can tell
you i mean i'm not an expert in
[Music]
in all these genetic things all i can
tell you is that this is what i see as
far as the trends that's what the
evidence shows to me and those are the
assumptions i make when i look at
homosexuality
okay and
here's another fellow talking about the
same subject there's a chemical that
seems to change orientation
called at atrazine a herbicide used
globally but banned in the eu can cause
chemical castration and complete
feminization in adult male frogs
oh
what do you think of that kermit turns
into miss kermit
uh
i don't know i looked it up and i find
something different okay it says
atrazine has been suspected a suspected
terror at the gen and that's uh
something that affects your birth okay
some studies reporting causes uh
reporting causing
demasculinization in male northern
leopard frogs okay haze okay fellow the
researcher found that exposure caused
male
tadpoles to turn into hermaphrodites
okay this study has not been it has not
been able to be replicated a 2003 epa
review of this study concluded that
overcrowding questionable sample
handling techniques and the failure of
the authors to disclose key details
including sample sizes
dose-response effects and the
variability of observed effects made it
difficult to assess the study's
credibility
so uh
first of all it doesn't change the sex i
think and
in other words i'm not sure they proved
that uh in any way or
observe that you don't like the word
uh
proof or observe they came up with that
theory that's their explanation but
first you gotta you gotta take the
explanation
from
what has happened
and if you if your assumptions don't
match your theory there's a there's no
um
there's there's no correlation between
the theory and the assumptions right
then we have a problem and that's
essentially what this uh epa report said
there they in other words in their
language they said they haven't proven
in we have not been able to replicate
those results meaning that they operated
out of the wrong assumptions okay they
used different assumptions to make their
theory not the assumptions that they
should have made okay
and again that's that's
how we look at it in rational science
okay another follow says regarding
population the injection will reduce the
population by 2030 maybe
he's talking about i guess the covid uh
injection okay
and uh so this is what uh we see here at
least in europe okay
uh this is lately
uh says that new cases are pushing
countries to introduce more stringent
measures
now whether these uh vaccines are gonna
cause people to die or the lack of them
we're gonna cause people to die well you
know that depends on opinions out there
a lot of people believe in one thing a
lot of people believe in another thing
okay
and so all i can tell you i'm i'm still
on the fence i'm not convinced that
there is
a uh a pandemic out there i have at
least i don't know anyone
who um
who has died or even has gotten sick
from this
i don't know anyone personal uh friends
or whatever some people i heard talk
about other people
and
they got sick apparently went to the
hospital and they were told they had
kobe did they really have cobit i don't
know
i can't tell you all i know i got the
shots i got the shots why because
otherwise they're going to make life
very very miserable for you
if you travel
and i had to travel and so i decided to
you know
just get the shots do i believe in the
shots do i believe there's covet out
there i don't know
right now i don't i can't tell you for
sure the only thing that makes me
suspect that there is a disease out
there okay and that people are dying
okay
is the fact that i cannot believe that
countries that are enemies of each other
would cooperate in other words i don't
think iran russia china
cuba would help the united states uh if
if the united states is pushing this
whole thing um
i don't think they would help the united
states
and the rich people who are making money
now selling vaccines and withhold this
whole thing
i don't think they would work for the
united states and say oh we're going to
do this to to our people as well
no i i don't think so so that's the only
thing that makes me suspect that there
is something going on out there uh
apparently the hospitals if i went to a
hospital i would find a lot of people
who are sick
and respirators and whatever and that
would probably give me an idea that yeah
there is some kind of problem out there
um
i can't tell you uh i haven't done that
work and i'm not interested in the
subject matter at all i took the shots
only because i'm going to travel i i i
did travel i'm sorry
okay um
i don't think the population will drop
because of vaccines or because you get
the shots or anything like that or even
anything related to disease i mean yeah
when you have a disease lots of people
die
population you could say goes down but
you know we reproduce and overcome that
and that's been the case throughout
history okay
uh i don't think that disease is now
going to be the limiting factor for
population
the limiting factor could be war for
sure that would take us to extinction
but the other one is the one that i
propose here and that's that
it's economics that's going to kill us
okay
and we might even die earlier than 2030
okay
[Music]
if there's war
anytime soon well yeah then you can
believe that there's going to probably
be a reduction in population maybe all
the way down to zero or very close to
zero uh if there isn't war there's still
going to be a problem because if
if the global economy cannot uh continue
running forever okay cannot you cannot
grow forever
okay
and part of that reason the reason for
that is that population doesn't grow
forever and population is demand and we
have a demand driven
economy man's economy is demand driven
you expect to sell more like all
companies right all corporations
expect to sell more next year and more
and more what does more mean population
and if population stagnates you know now
we're
growing asymptotically
globally
we're growing asymptotically
population-wise demographically
then at some point the global economy is
going to come to a dead stop
when it does not if but when it does
whenever it happens i can't tell you the
date but when it happens
we're going to have
major economic problems
especially when you
consider that growth like i talked about
in a couple of sessions
back
has to do with
goods with tangible goods
you make a highway you make a house you
make a you know a boat
an airplane
even a field all those tangibles that's
growth
okay you don't grow uh doing services
services is not growth
and so right now we're expanding the
services putting people to work and just
uh spreading the
money around that's all we're doing
we're not creating anything with
services really
uh it's only those things that produce
something tangible that
creates growth
and so yeah i think that we're headed to
a point where the global economy doesn't
grow anymore
for all those reasons and
when we come to a dead stop at that
point
it's a lot of people lose their jobs
they have no place to go everybody
cannot be in the entertainment and ad
business
and so the global economy collapses
if
war doesn't happen before then because
again there's going to be a fight for
the resources meaning
uh who not resources in the sense that
the earth doesn't have enough resources
to sustain us
right now
that's still farther away you know same
as climate change those things are in
the future right now it would be
who controls what country and consult to
those countries and if china has some
countries russia and some others and the
united states has some others at some
point you know those groups are going to
collide against each other
you know their areas of influence are
going to overlap and that's when there's
going to be probably a war
so yeah a war might happen before the
collapse but war will be a result of
economics as well
that's my five cents worth
okay let's move on to energy and i
talked about energy the other day i was
going to talk about a different subject
today but uh some issues came up and i
thought i had to uh
you know go back and uh
cross all the t's and dot the eyes okay
some people seem to have lots of
questions now what did i say in general
very simple
energy is not a physical object
okay energy is a mathematical concept
therefore
you cannot say that you're going to
transfer energy because in physics the
word transfer has to be taken literally
okay so you can transfer a box you can
transfer a rock you can transfer a tree
you can transfer a house or whatever has
to be a physical object then you can
talk about transferring in physics you
cannot say you're going to transfer a
concept such as love or intelligence or
data or information
and certainly you cannot transfer energy
we're done that's it that was
in a nutshell if you didn't understand
that well you're a religious fanatic
you're a person who has memorized stuff
in college the word energy was shoved
very deep
into you
and uh your whole religion collapses
without it and that's why you're gonna
defend that word to the end of your life
because otherwise your life is
meaningless
okay
you have no theory you have no
explanation because you rely on that
spiritual word
okay so some people raise some issues
let's look at those and uh some are
questions some are comments so here it
is okay one file says in physics energy
is defined as the capacity
is there a physical object called
capacity do you can you can you draw a
picture of a standalone object called
capacity
and the answer is no can you touch
capacity can you see capacity no
you can't see your touch
because there's nothing to see or touch
assuming you use the definitions of
mathematical physics so it dies there
and in rational science you know
capacity is a concept there's no issue
with that and so if it's a concept the
question is
can we talk about transfer okay again
physically transferring
and so
fal says it may exist
well not in science in science only
object can be said to exist concepts do
not exist okay so
that ends there as well
to say energy hasn't been defined as
ludicrously absurd
okay well it has been defined in fact if
i'll define it there capacity that's how
it's defined in fact the big problem
really is this one let me show it to you
it's that it's defined in several ways
that's the big problem
it's a quantitative
property it's uh again capacity and
ability
it's
taken to be a thing because they talk
about transferring of energy
it's equated to mass in
einstein's famous equation
and here's just an example the
lagrangian it's uh defined as a kinetic
minus the potential energy and they have
all these other categories okay
energy is defined as a concept but
treated as a thing what is a thing it's
that which has shape what is a concept
well that which doesn't in a nutshell
okay that's the quick version of the
word energy and here you see it okay you
see
what mathematical physics all these
types of energies they have mechanical
electric magnetic gravitational
i like the next to the last one the rest
energy i mean what is the rest energy
okay
and yeah it's uh the one that uses rest
mass which is another irrational concept
what do you mean rest mass hopefully
masses always rest because mass is the
quantity of matter and all you have to
do is count how many atoms you have
in the rock and then you know what the
mass of the rock is it's a gazillion
atoms that's what the mass would be but
that's not how they do it they talk
about rust mass because they're really
talking about but they're talking about
gravity they're talking about weight and
they call this mass they call it weight
uh then they call this weight they call
it mass
and uh mathematical physic has you know
rust energy which is
uh again
it's uh it's weight
which is pressed against something when
it moves and when it doesn't move it
just you know has quantity of atoms and
that's the rust energy more or less okay
so yeah but see uh this is the same
thing they had in traditional religions
where they use all these words that are
more or less synonyms of energy you have
soul spirit conscience
mind thought etc and these words are the
ones religious people use they talk
about all these words and they think
that these words represent physical
objects
well not in science and there's nothing
different between mathematical physics
and traditional religions they take all
these concepts
and they turn them into physical objects
and then begin to move them around
that's the big problem okay
okay so give me a second here let me
take this out of here so this is where
the problem is the problem is that uh
well let me continue here this file says
also transfer of energy is the
conversion
he's gonna explain what transfer means
okay
so he's gonna go in this rigmarole it's
not it's not that transfer is what
everybody understands by transfer this
is transfer i have a little ball and i'm
going to transfer it to this hand from
the left hand to the right hand that's
called transfer
that's transfer in physics okay very
simple very straightforward baby like
kindergarten stuff okay
no mystery that's what transfer means
but here they're going to give you the
runaround because they have to show you
what transfer really means
transfer energy energy is the conversion
of one form of energy into another
so that's what transfer means according
to these people
and i like the next one it says or the
measure the movement of energy
[Laughter]
see so they take this content they they
they define it as a capacity and now
they're going to transfer the capacity
and they say we're going to move the
capacity
here i'm going to move it
yeah so so they use these uh figures of
speech
okay
that's what they're doing that's what
they're introducing figures of speech of
ordinary speech
and uh you know euphemisms and they want
to do their theories with these youth
feminisms
uh no that's okay i mean if you want to
use poetry no problem in your
presentation like at the end of your
presentation when you do your closing
arguments yeah you can use poetry you
can use figures of speech you know uh
it's okay to play around with the words
but when you're giving the core of your
theory when you're giving an explanation
of a mechanism
that's got to be literal
that's got to be literal in physics you
got to say look here's the ball give me
you know take a ball here's the ball
and i transfer it that's called transfer
you can't say well what i really meant
no not not in physics you can't can't
use euphemism you can't use figures of
speech and say well it's really a
conversion of one energy into another so
far you said absolutely nothing all you
did was hide the fact that you don't
know anything about physics
that's what you did okay
okay here's another fellow and he says
uh energy as a concept might not have a
place in explanatory physics
i thought that's what physics was all
about 150 percent of it
isn't explanatory physics that
actual physics i mean isn't explanations
of mechanism what physics is all about
what else is physics about
you have to explain how this universe
works
you have to explain gravity you have to
explain
how magnetism works you have to explain
you know how the atom works that's what
you got to explain so that's what
physics is about you can't use the word
energy for that because you have to use
objects to do that to explain the
mechanism you need objects you can't do
it with concepts such as you know energy
but he says it's not a spirit well it
looks like to me i mean uh the capacity
uh
what is that is that a physical object
if it's not a i mean if if it's not a
concept it's an object and if it's not
an object's a concept there are no other
categories in the dictionary either it
has shape or refers to that which has
shape or refers to that which doesn't in
other words to a relation between two
objects that's it yeah there are no
other categories
god is either a physical object or god
is a concept
love
grace whatever
god cannot be both
okay that's the issue invisible for the
purposes of physics in ordinary speech
you can say whatever you want okay the
gas in my car has the capacity
to make my car work so i can say that
gas is an instance of energy
no no gas is not energy
gas is gas and energy is energy here so
so let's point to this well what what
where he's going wrong okay
gas is a physical object okay it's an
object energy is a concept
energy is not equal to gas gas is not
equal to energy you must define the word
object the the terms uh you know the
categories object and concept before you
talk
otherwise you're going to get into the
circular reasoning okay
energy is not equal to gas
okay
gas what is gas gas is made of atoms
it's finite it's single frame okay you
can take a snapshot of gas especially
one that's visible uh we can't of those
that are invisible but maybe you could
do it with uh you know some ultraviolet
light or whatever but energy you can't
take a picture of because energy is a
mathematical concept
it's a magnitude it's got units
okay
so energy has is totally different than
gas
okay so that's what's wrong with that
okay
so you cannot have what he says that we
can't have an abstraction to this why
can't we have an extraction to describe
things well because science is not about
describing that's the issue the science
is about explaining that's that's what
you got to do in physics
and
you know you can't say well
gas is energy and energy is gas because
all you're doing right there is talking
about uh thing words of ordinary speech
you know we say oh put some energy in
your tank yeah that's okay in ordinary
speech you can't use that terminology in
physics okay that's where the problem
comes in
and people don't understand that they
bring all this language from ordinary
speech
because the mathematicians do and so
they say well you know the the phd there
from harvard you know he used the word
energy over here and he used it over
there as well yeah they do because they
they never did physics
physics has to do with physical objects
you can't do physics without a physical
object you need an object
and uh you can't move concepts around
you can move gas around gas because
just very simple it's made out of atoms
okay so if it's made out of atoms it had
better be an object because
one atom is an object
it's a thing
it's got shape
okay and if you take a bunch of atoms
you know uh gas and you put it in outer
space if you could
had the eyes of god you could see for
example air it would have shape it's a
blob
in a regular shape but it has shape
you can't do that with energy there is
no physical what are you going to put
out there what is energy made of
atoms
more energy spirits what is it made out
of
no energy is a concept a mathematical
concept and it's been driven so deep in
people's mind that you know energy is a
physical object that it's transferred
that gas is energy and so on that they
can't get out of that they're they're in
this religion they're hypnotized to
believe uh
you know energy is is an object and is
treated as a physical object not the
case okay
okay another follow-up lots of people
have problems with this okay bill gates
define energy as a curse word
that is religion not science
okay first of all i didn't define it see
i don't use the word energy except when
i want to relate to
what the mathematicians call energy in
terms of the rope model that's the only
time i just want to show people what it
really what these people are talking
about when they talk about this concept
called energy then i put it in terms of
the rope model but we don't use the word
energy at all in physics okay this is
the word energy belongs strictly to
religion to the religion of mathematics
okay so we don't use that word at all
it's used
by the mathematicians because they are
concerned not about explaining they're
concerned about describing they need to
put a number n units in an equation
that's where that's the proper place for
this word energy
but we have problem because they then
they give you the physical
interpretation of that and they say well
we move the trans we transfer the energy
or whatever okay and we transformed the
energy from this kind of energy to that
one like if they were using silly putty
or you know uh whatever you know and
building a statue with i'd say we
transform the silly putty into the
statue that's more or less what they
try to convey to you when they say well
we took potential energy and turned it
into
kinetic energy or they took chemical
energy and turned it into kinetic energy
they're trying to say that they
manipulated they molded this energy and
turned it into something else
and all they're doing is
talking about really equations they're
saying that we turn this
type of energy
meaning a number in a unit into this
type of energy meaning this number and
unit
you know so this this is where the
you have to grasp that because unless
you understood that you don't understand
what uh conversion of energy means or
what transfer of energy means okay and
yeah
i didn't define it but here you have
different uh notions uh one notion that
mathematical physics has is that energy
is a capacity in the ability that's how
it's defined in most dictionaries then
you find this equation e equals mc
squared energy equals mass times
velocity of light squared
einstein's equation so so you have these
different notions what does energy what
does capacity have to do with that
equation
okay capacity is a different definition
i mean are we talking about a definition
here or is this
um a uh
just an equation
i mean is an equation a description is
an equation just a um a tactology what
is that
okay i mean can we say those two are
equal the fact that you define something
with words and say that's the capacity
and then you put an equation say these
two things are equal
this is the issue
and uh then another notion is that you
know energy is not equal to is not not
an object energy is a concept and you
can't transfer concepts so again i
didn't define this word and i don't use
it like that it's the mathematicians who
do this so if anything the curse word is
them is the one that they introduced not
me okay
and i'm just the bottom line any use of
the word energy as a thing such as in
transfer energy converts to mass etc is
irrational you can't use this notion in
physics
and people have problems again because
you know if if ever
you destroy the word energy you destroy
their religion it's the most important
word of mathematical physics you know
energy and again it's a spirit whenever
you don't understand something you
introduce the word spirit and says oh
the spirit moved
the curtain
uh the spirit is the one that came and
talked to me at night
and as long as you don't
you know you treat spirit as this soul
this
that comes out of you
and you treat it as a physical entity
that has mass weight
shape
you know uh walks talks
well then yeah
then we have a problem we can't follow
what you're saying i mean what is this
spirit that you talk about pale face you
know
okay and
yeah it's not me who doesn't understand
here he says we aren't allowed to use
energy anymore because bill can't figure
out what
it is
no it's not me it's feinstein who
doesn't know what it is he says it is
important to realize that in physics
today we have no knowledge of what
energy is
yeah fine and couldn't figure out that
he was talking about a concept so you
can't use the word what
in the context of energy energy is not a
what and another fellow also along the
same line said ricky's sentence is
correct the language used is
grammatically correct okay
he correctly used the words what is to
correctly express his thoughts we have
no knowledge
what energy is
and he sends me to a
link he says listen to this music and
the music's called what is love
and again in ordinary speech you can say
what is energy and ordinary speech you
can say what is love not in science not
in physics physic there is no such thing
as love no such thing as energy okay and
so that's what we're referring to you
can only use the word what
in the context of objects you can say
what is a tree okay and you point to it
and
you say what is a dog what is a rock
then and you point to it then you can
use the word what but you cannot say
what is intelligence
that's an irrational statement in
physics
in ordinary speech you can ask that
question you can use whatever you want
and nobody's going to pay attention to
it to the language and you'll say it's
grammatically correct
in science it's not correct it's
irrational you can't say what is
intelligence what is information what is
a soul what is conscience
you can't ask that question
it's irrational it's an irrational
question you can only ask what is a
thing you know what is a tree what is a
rock
and the answer has to be you point to it
and name it and say that's a rock that's
a tree that's a house that's a dog
that's how it's answered you have to
point and name that's the only answer
allowed
okay
now
uh concepts we define so you have to say
give me the definition
of such and such word
and you either point and name
objects
or you define concepts
okay so you can't say what is such and
such concept not in physics so you have
a different language in physics okay so
you need to know the difference between
an object and a concept before you use
the wrong terminology to even ask the
question okay so no in physics it's not
grammatically correct to say what is
energy
vol says
to transfer means to move from one place
to another to move and to transfer our
synonyms okay like that so essentially
it means to change location
okay i like that too
the energy changes location
so he takes the energy from here and
moves it over there all these words they
move you know
it's very scary stuff they move the
energy so this is the problem people
treat it as a physical object they think
they can transfer energy they think they
can move energy from one location to
another
and they're talking about mathematical
amounts and units
that's what energy is
energy is a concept mathematical concept
you don't move number fives you don't
move meters okay or or whatever joules
or you know kevs
okay uh another foul says keyword
transformation
okay
keyword turn into
the object had a translation
it
moved
so again these people are moving
concepts they believe that energy is a
physical object and they use these
euphemisms
we transformed it
and what do you mean by transform well
we moved it we transferred it
and what do you mean by that we
converted it and so they use all these
euphemisms instead of saying look this
is very simple this is the object here i
transferred it
okay
that's called trans uh to transfer and
transformation you know i can take uh
you know again uh
clay and turn it into a statue then i
transformed the clay into a statue
that's how we use the words in physics
you can't say you're going to transform
a concept
that's that's where these people go
wrong okay
and again you know we can create um
concepts all the time
i create them every day
in fact ask any programmer out there
they constantly create concepts
because what they're really
doing is um
you know imagining new uh
new terms
new concepts out there and and you know
they say we created a concept
but see that crew when you create a
concept it's not the same thing as to
create an object
we have to be very careful with using
the word create because we say well we
create things every day yeah we create
concepts
okay and we we do not create objects
meaning
take nothing absolutely nothing
empty space vacuum
and suddenly produce length width and
height
produce a shape out of nothing
not even god can do that
and you might say well how do you know
he's all powerful yeah yeah
all you have to do is explain the
mechanism you know the process how he
transformed nothing into something just
if you can explain the mechanism be
great if you cannot explain the
mechanism don't tell me that god can do
it
god can come here and tell me okay but
don't you try to tell me that okay
because
all you're telling me is you believe
that
you don't you have to explain the
mechanism if you want uh people to
understand you let alone believe you
and right now we can't understand you
because you say you don't know how god
does it of course not you cannot even
imagine something popping in from the
void
you know spontaneously surreptitiously
and so
yeah not even god can create something
from nothing
and you know
it's one of those issues that you know
you cannot avoid you have to explain
otherwise your statement is worthless
all you're telling us that you believe
in managing that's all you told us so
far
okay uh here's a one thou he says
energy is not a concept oh
one guy who objects to treating it as a
concept we point to it
i'm pointing to energy okay
i point to the delta
the delta what do you mean the delta
what's a delta uh letter d uh greek
letter d is that what delta is
says i point to the part of the image
that changed between the frames of the
video
so we have there a video right and we
take two frames we have 505 and 506 you
can put a look at another two frames if
you want and he's pointing to the delta
to something between them i don't know i
don't know there's no frame in between
but he says that he's pointing to some
kind of frame that's in between
two adjacent frames
so i don't know what he's pointing to
what this delta thing is but he says i'm
not pointing to the change okay i'm
pointing to the delta
go back to the delta okay the difference
between
so he's going to talk about a difference
he's saying that delta is this
difference i guess that's what the word
letter d stands for difference so you're
going to point to the difference well
difference is not a physical object
there is no physical standalone object
called difference
okay and so i can show you the energy
between your start of the video and the
end of your video the difference between
the snapshots or your energy so you're
saying the difference is the energy
i hope someone understood because uh you
know no one can understand at least i
can't okay
okay here's an example okay
here's bill when he was two years old
and bill at 20.
and that's 18 years difference i guess
is that's the delta
and uh you know it sounds like a ricco
sentence
know your honor uh i'm not a
racketeering uh guy i was a communist
same difference son
[Laughter]
your honor i can't do 18 years
i'm 84 years old i can't do 18 years
well sir you do as many as you can
what the hell is this delta i mean we're
talking about 18 years is the the
beginning of
one frame and the ending of another
frame in my movie
what the hell is this delto i i didn't
see any energy i just saw two pictures
where where was the delta okay
and i can show you energy between your
start of the video and the end of your
video well
where was it what is it the 18 years is
that what the delta was i mean i don't
know uh maybe if someone's smarter than
me can figure it out okay uh i don't
understand this fall at all
okay and here's uh another thousands and
the day after veritasium utters this
nonsense and another follows uh points
to the same video he says thought this
might amuse you relates to what is
electricity
so talking about pointing at deltas well
this guy
uh brings up john pointing okay pointing
came up with a pointing vector what was
that
that was represents the directional
energy flux the energy transfer of an
electromagnetic field
and so if you take the uh standard
electromagnetic wave the transverse wave
you know james maxwell's wave well you
have this electric field
which is a bunch of vectors abstraction
again
and
then you have the magnetic field which
is also a bunch of vectors another one
that's running apparently perpendicular
to one to the other
okay
and they move
and
energy
uh according to pointing john pointing
there this vowel uh moves perpendicular
to both so here you have uh i don't know
electric field and this is your magnetic
field then towards your eyes what you
have is the energy flow energy meaning
you know the photons they flow into your
eyes that's the energy you're getting
from the sun that's essentially what the
notion that john pointing came up with
and he says you can apply that
also to electricity that's going to be
uh this mueller's uh veritasium um
that's got to be his argument he's
saying yeah just like we did it with
light
electromagnetism right we can do it also
with electricity that's going to be his
point in
in that uh video
that had almost five million hits okay
okay let's see what he's uh going to
talk to us about what uh this fall
mulder is going to tell us
and he says the following okay he says
that you know again energy flux is
perpendicular to magnetic field and
electric field and he's going to replace
those really essentially with
electricity so he's going to do the same
thing that he did with light he's going
to do it with electricity okay so that's
his argument
and these are the two questions that
he's going to try to answer okay here it
is
yeah she says if the flow of current is
two ways okay current remember you have
alternating current goes in one
direction then goes in the other
direction so when the power plant
produces electricity it produces
alternating current okay and so it goes
to your home and then it also comes back
to them and it goes back and forth
uh you know constantly
that's the notion we have right
and so if flow current is two ways okay
he says then why does energy flow in one
direction
yeah good question okay and the issue is
here she says when those same electrons
flow back to the power station okay
why are they also not carrying energy
back from your home to the power station
because you wouldn't have to pay i guess
any energy if you provide the power
station back with the energy they gave
you to begin with
be great right you have zero electric
bill
so are you sending electricity or energy
back to the power station well he says
no it only flows to your home but not
from your home to the power station
okay so it flows one way even though
electricity flows both ways okay the
alternating current
so see see what his argument is that's
what he's going to try to show you in
his uh movie his uh video okay let's see
where it leads
so he starts out by doing this he's uh
going to start by explaining to you a
little bit of what electricity is
and he already bombs out here because he
says you know you have the flow of
uh
electrons
which he's later gonna say electrons
don't really flow like you know going
all around
he says they move very little and in
fact an alternating printer they go just
very little back and forth that's all
they just shake back and forth
which is not what he's showing there
there he's showing a single
uh motion of the electrons direct
current i guess right
and but the current flow he shows it in
the opposite direction
and he says well it's conventional flow
you know conventional electricity uh has
a different uh direction than the
electrons
and so we have a problem because he's
already confusing us he's saying look
the electrons go in that direction which
he's later gonna say they don't because
they go back and forth they just vibrate
like back and forth in situ
that's the first issue and then the
other one is that he's showing that
they're flowing
but then he's got the current flowing in
the opposite direction very confusing
stuff and he doesn't clarify that he
just continues right okay so we start
off on the wrong foot because uh his
what he's explaining doesn't match what
he's illustrating that's where we start
off on the wrong foot but that's the
least of his problems it just gets worse
here it goes okay
he goes into and shows this he says look
when the electrons flow they create this
electric field all around the circuit
okay
and um
and so it's all around the wires okay so
this electric field is going to be
important because you know he's going to
use this to show that it's this field
that's eventually going to move the
electrons around
so the movement of the electrons creates
a field which in the field is the one
that moves the electrons around we have
a circular argument there we don't know
which came first the chicken or the egg
okay so okay that's that's a starting
point
which again not very irrational
but this is this is where we have a
problem okay here's the electric field
pushes electrons around
what do you mean the electric field
pushes the electrons i thought the
electrons created the elect the electric
field
that extends throughout the circuit okay
so so again we have this
this contradiction there we in in
understanding in the language that he
uses to express himself okay and again
what he talks about does not match
what he's illustrating okay
okay so we continue here's uh he's going
to try and explain this pointing vector
because he's going to say that remember
the
electric and magnetic fields are
perpendicular to each other and the
energy right travels perpendicular to
both
remember that that's important
okay
he's going to show that uh the pointing
vector in other words the energy travels
perpendicular to both the electric field
and magnetic field which is what they
claim
happens with light he's going to show
the same thing for electricity i want to
reinforce that okay okay so he says the
current inside the wires creates a
magnetic field outside the wires
well it also creates a magnetic field
inside the wires for that matter i mean
you can see the circles the blue circles
they go inside the wires as well
so it's not only that they create a
field outside the wires it creates it
inside the wires as well that's the
first problem the second problem is that
he's got uh
he talks about the right hand rule but
he's going to use the left hand rule
look at the motion of the
electric
of the
electrons okay the electrons are moving
in this case counterclockwise okay you
can see the green ones going around the
circuit
and what he's going to say that these
electrons as you can see he's going to
use that top
hand which is the right hand rule but
he's actually
illustrating the left hand rule which is
the electrons going down and the
magnetic field curled around in the
direction of his fingers so he's using
the left-hand rule and he's calling it
the right-hand rule
so again we have more problems here
because what he's illustrating doesn't
match what he's saying but he says
according to pointing theory energy
should be flowing and that he can figure
out the right hand rule okay this is
what he's trying to say let's go over
that slowly so that you can see what
he's doing here here's the let's uh put
us uh stop the
picture there okay you can see uh what's
happening you can see his fingers are
curled look at how his fingers are
curled okay that's important okay here
you have first this is the electric
field there okay it's moving downwards
in the circuit so both thumbs are
downwards so far we're okay okay the
electric field is okay how about the
magnetic field well the magnetic field
is running in the opposite direction
okay because the magnetic field is
moving if you look at it from the bottom
it's moving clockwise and what he's
showing is counterclockwise with his
fingers
okay he's moving his fingers are curled
in the opposite direction of the arrow
that you see in the magnetic field and
this is going to become a problem
because you know here's the energy flow
okay and the energy is flowing
parallel to the magnetic field
he wants to give you the idea that the
electric field is going down whereas the
magnetic field is coming into your eyes
and energy is flowing perpendicular to
both
actually the magnetic field is going all
around the wire and if you're looking
from the side it's going to go into your
eyes if you look it from behind it's
going to go into your eyes and if you
look at it from the left it's going to
go into your eyes no matter how you look
at it that magnetic field is twirling
around the wire so the energy flow is
going to be parallel to the magnetic
field it's not perpendicular as he
originally said he was going to prove
that's the point i'm trying to make okay
okay so let's look at what happens at
the battery okay
the battery goes into more of the same
thing okay he's uh again going to use
call it the right hand rule but he's
actually you know talking about the left
hand rule in other words the
illustration doesn't match what he's
saying
and uh there you see we go close to the
battery and you can see the direction of
the electric field he says the electric
field is downwards uh the magnetic field
is into your eyes which is not true it's
all around it's not into your eyes
because if you look at it from the right
it's also going to go into your eyes
you're going to look at it from the left
or from behind it's also going to go
into your eyes no matter how you look at
it it's going to go into your eyes and
that means that the energy flow is going
to go parallel to
the magnetic field
and that's aside from the fact that he's
got the right hand rule uh it's when
he's uh illustrating the left-hand rule
okay so this he's got two problems there
and here you let's uh stop that so that
you can see it okay that's what it looks
like okay you see the magnetic field is
into your eyes supposedly electric field
is downwards and energy is to the right
okay and that's not really what what
he's shown with his hand there the the
one on the right i put the right the
correct hand on the left which is the
left hand rule and you can see that
matches exactly what he's illustrating
okay so yeah we have a problem with uh
what he says with respect to what he
illustrates it's very confusing
and again people don't catch these
things they just bow and say yeah okay i
understood when they didn't understand
squat
okay so here he goes into a little more
detail he says uh look then
we can show that the energy flows in one
direction okay which is from the battery
to
uh whatever receives it the lamp or
whatever is on the other side which is
what he's trying to show with the power
plant he says the power plant gives you
energy but you don't give it back
because the flow of energy is one way
okay
and so he says the
transfer of energy along the way you can
use the right hand rule to find the
energy is flowing to the right okay
and on the top
is the same as on the bottom they flow
to the right okay
and um so yeah i don't know um here's a
little more detail of that maybe okay
you can see says it's the field not the
electrons that move well let's start
here it says even though the electrons
go two ways
away from the battery and towards it
by using the pointing vector you can
find that the energy flux only goes one
way
okay
and it's the fields and not the
electrons that carry the energy well we
have a problem here because what he's
saying is that the reason
the cause the mechanism right that's
what we're trying to explain here the
reason energy goes to the right is
because of the pointing vector
that's not an explanation that's that's
uh
that's saying look the reason pointing
came up with this vector is he went out
there he looked at this and he says okay
i'm going to come up with my vector
saying that energy flows in this
direction okay so that's a description
now they're going to use that
description to prove or to explain the
mechanism of why energy flows to the
right and that's not an explanation
that's just the regurgitating
regurgitation of pointing's vector
so he hasn't explained anything all he
said is you know
energy goes to the right because he goes
to the right because the pointing vector
says so and pointing got the
his mathematical description from
observing a circuit and say well yeah
energy always flows to the right
so he hasn't explained anything
so not only do we have a problem with um
with the fact that
this
mueller
does not illustrate what he says or does
not state what he's illustrating he's
not describing that that's one issue the
right-hand rule he's illustrating the
left-hand rule that's one issue but the
other one is he's using the pointing
vector to explain
why energy goes in one direction
and you cannot use an equation
to explain something
you have to explain physically why
energy whatever energy is is flowing in
one direction which is what he was
trying to prove from the start saying
look you know the energy comes from the
power station to your house but it
doesn't go back
well why not we still don't know what's
because of the pointing vector and it
points you know a pointing vector
you know he knows that energy according
to the pointing vector goes one way but
that's not an explanation
that's just saying you know we've
verified in the lab you know by running
experiments that energy flows in this
direction and when does it flow in that
direction because of the pointing vector
what is the pointing vector well it's a
mathematical description of energy
flowing one way that's why it's called a
vector
okay so let's get down to conclusions
with all this energy
nonsense okay
uh laymen can routinely confuse energy
for a physical object that's a big big
problem and against laymen people who
have very little understanding of
physics
energy is a mathematical concept in
other words you can't transfer concepts
you can't say you're going to transfer
energy
and again it's a fight between ordinary
speech versus scientific language
you cannot use euphemisms or figures of
speech you have to use the real mccoy if
you're going to talk about transfer you
have to talk about objects only you
can't say that you're going to transfer
a concept
veritasium derek this foul muller uses
ordinary speech that he memorized in
college to make his case
very derek has energy parallel to the
magnetic field when it should be
perpendicular to it
very derrick illustrates left-hand rule
and calls it the right-hand rule very
derrick hasn't explained the cause of
energy flow in one direction all he said
is it's because of the pointing vector
and very derek hasn't explained why the
cause the mechanism energy from your
house does not go back to the power
station in the enormous closed circuit
and what's interesting his video
received almost 5 million views that i
saw it this morning
he put it out on my birthday number 19
20 21 thank you mr derek and there were
248 thousand
up fingers
out of that 5 million
interesting
that's how many people did not catch any
of this they just called they just went
in there for entertainment
and that's all they did because they
didn't understand squad of what derek
was trying to explain
so my corollary veritasium derek
memorized what authority fed him in
college to obtain his phd he never
questioned the catechism barry derek's
phd is worthless it's just a piece of
paper
that's not worth the paper it's printed
on
he has not explained why energy flows
one way
a description is not an explanation
pointing's vector is only a description
a mathematical description that cannot
explain to you the cause of why this
mysterious thing called energy which is
a concept flows from the power station
to your house and why you get a bill
every month
okay
let's go with some of the questions some
of the comments people made this week
since last time
one week ago because i was in south
america having a great time with my wife
we had a good time over there
okay surface contact paul says there is
always a superficial contact between
objects there are no isolated objects
all things are in contact the void does
not exist
i like the fact they use the he uses a
uh
an article in front of the word void
which is a concept not in physics that's
again ordinary speech this person has
not learned to talk
properly in physics okay
and yeah concepts do not exist
so the void does not exist it's
irrational to say that a concept exists
only objects may be said to exist
the space as you call it you cannot call
it into play because it's not it does
not exist
yeah
again he uses his word exist and that's
going to be part of the problem
here let me clarify that
you must define something and nothing
okay you must define object and space
and you must define exist
object
something right that which has shape
what is space nothing that which doesn't
we're done what is exist an object must
be an object that has location so we
have our definitions
if you have better definitions we would
like to hear them okay
and
it doesn't mean that
you're going to use authority or
tradition democracy any of that no what
you're going to use is rationality you
have to defend your definition
we're going to be glad to attack it to
analyze it okay
and so you got to define these words
before you can talk right now this
person's not making any sense because
he's going around in circles he says
between the moon and the earth there is
the black sky which is something
absolutely not that black sky is known
as nothing there is nothing there there
is no object there
and if you think there is an object you
have to draw this black sky okay without
anything else in there you got to show
us
what contours this black sky
okay if you cannot show us what contours
the black sky the the universe space
uh then space is not a physical object
and neither is that black sky there that
you mentioned
everyone conceived the blast guy black
sky as something we don't care what
everyone does we don't care about
democracy we don't care about authority
or tradition
okay
something that which i shape nothing
that which doesn't we have to have
definitions okay so we don't care what
people say or what people have used all
these years in fact we're challenging
what people have used all these years
okay another follow says
says all things uh oh no this is my
analysis of the spells also says all
things are not in contact yeah nothing
means space vacuum surrounds every
object
okay it's nothing which surrounds every
object pun intended okay provides
contrast contour you need contour in
order to
to
conceptualize shape to visualize safe to
imagine shape okay
no two objects are in contact okay
contact
two objects become one single piece
and that doesn't happen in our macro
world
okay
you press your finger against your other
finger against a table or against the
ball or against anything the rock
you have not touched it
i press harder
you have not touched it how do i know
because they're still separated
the only way that you have touch is
these two fingers become one
then you have touch
that doesn't happen
okay because even at the molecular level
you don't have that
you don't have atoms uh you know
becoming one or you know like a table
with a chair
uh they don't become one
there's always space separating each
atom okay now in mother nature's world
that's a little different okay uh her
invisible world the ropes yeah they can
certainly become one momentarily when
they go through each other i guess right
so it's a little different in the
invisible world because it has different
properties
okay
the rope and the thread they have
different properties
okay and so you can't use these
definitions meanings of ordinary speech
in science okay so in order to
conceptualize two objects you need to
have space around them
okay there there's something surrounding
something providing contrast to an
object the backdrop okay we call that
space ultimately right it's space
and the only way you can have
touch
is if two objects become one okay now
you have touch
okay and even in that case you have
space meaning nothing meaning vacuum
surrounding the
void so yeah you gotta understand the
language of rational science because we
have to conceptualize we have to try to
understand what you're saying you can't
use the words of ordinary speech the
notions of ordinary speech
specifically of the mathematicians okay
because they screwed up all the language
okay here's um
another file says mathematics is cold
hard science
okay
uh well these are the errors or
the irrationalities that mathematics has
okay they treat concepts as objects um
they use inconsistence definitions or
undefined terms i mean here you have
energy's got like 10 different uh
definitions uh what was it mass has
seven weight has at least four or five
okay so they use
they have all these definitions they
don't they don't have a definition
everybody sinks their teeth and says
okay we understand it now because this
guy mentions one definition the other
guy uses another one and they don't see
eye to eye they're not communicating
because they use different definitions
and then describing and claiming to have
explained that's what mathematics does
and the other one is that the mechanisms
don't work or cannot be imagined i mean
how do you imagine a particle at two
places at once
how does a rock
how can a rock be at two places at once
so to speak in the macro world they say
it's for the microscopic world but it's
the same thing how can one particle be
at two places at once
okay or have two states as they say you
know vibrating a nod or vibing more and
less
makes no sense you cannot even imagine
what they're saying
uh and so they end up with irrational
conclusions and here are some examples
particle can be in two places at once
the black hole singularity moves a star
far away you know because it's got this
uh ingredient that nobody can put their
finger on which is called mass
they say because of this mass it trolls
you know far away stars around
how did it do it i mean i need to know
the mechanism don't tell me you did it
through mass what is this mass
messy what you do on sundays you know
big bang creationism the creation of
matter forget about matter creation of
space from nothing when space is nothing
so
i don't know you got to define nothing
first
so that we know what everything came out
of
came out of nothing and what came out of
nothing nothing
because space is nothing okay traveling
through time you know these people
travel through time and then uh
uh light mediated by something called a
wave pack that's something no one can
even imagine i mean you cannot draw this
thing what is a wave packet
you know please draw it
so yeah they have all these irrational
conclusions so i don't think it's maybe
it's cold and dark maybe in in
the worst sense of those words
gravity is caused by magic ropes that
never tangle ah
if they don't touch anything they don't
connect anything they are just math
lines you might as well call it a field
okay let's find out
is what this person says is criticism of
the rope model okay
and particles that never collide have
you ever heard of those
i mean you're saying magical ropes how
about magical particles
you're saying that ropes never tangle
well do particles ever collide
how is it that two particles can be at
the same place at the same time that's
called you know superposition
and then you have you know uh the
coherence more or less that you have a
particle in two places at once how do
you conceptualize any of that
so before you can attack the magic ropes
how about attacking the magic particles
and then uh for sure you can't touch the
mediator of gravity okay here let me let
me illustrate that for you okay
[Music]
here's a
pencil and i'm gonna let it drop okay
fell downwards okay let it repeatable we
have to do it twice so that's scientific
so we'll let go of the pencil and you'll
find out it doesn't go upwards it goes
downwards always goes downwards okay
no matter how many times i try i try to
have it go upwards it always goes
downwards but if you look there's
nothing above
nothing in front
you can do this at home by don't take my
word for it okay you don't see anything
here you can't touch anything here
except air air is not causing the
gravity nobody says that
okay so um you can't see your touch
gravity
so hopefully hopefully okay
you know the mediator of gravity has to
be invisible and intangible
if for some reason you go to the lab and
then you come to the conference and say
oh i was able to touch gravity the
mediator of gravity i was able to see
the mediator of gravity
well that ain't gravity because gravity
is
invisible and intangible the mediator of
gravity okay is invisible and intangible
so hopefully whatever you explained at
the conference had better be related to
invisibility and intangibility and yeah
so
the rope is invisible and intangible
okay so we're consistent with the
properties that gravity has
the day we can touch gravity man that's
very scary
you better not be able to touch the
mediator of gravity or see it
and so yeah we're consistent with
gravity what you're
asking there's uh you know here it is uh
is inconsistent with gravity if you're
expecting to touch
uh you know the mediator of gravity
and an intangible robe is again
consistent with gravity and rope doesn't
really connect okay i want to make sure
that people understand that there is no
real we use the word connect but it's
it's not really a connection in
in the sense of attaching okay
uh rope is just a continuation of the
thread remember the thread turns into
atoms which turn into rose which turned
into atoms which turn into ropes
it's all a big string in the entire
universe okay it's uh
all we're saying is that all these atoms
are interconnected by ropes and it's a
single
um closed loop thread that's what our
universe is that in space right but i'm
looking at the matter in the universe so
it's not attached like when you attach
something like you know put a
i don't know a hook onto something like
if it's a separate thing that you're
attaching not in that sense in that
sense it's not connected it's just one
thing turns into the other it's like you
know if i have this rope and this rope
at the end
the same threads these two strands turn
into you know a balloon and then the
balloon turns into another rope and the
rope into another balloon and so on in
that sense they're attached okay or
bound or whichever word you want to use
okay it's continuous thread
the electromagnetic rope is magical when
compared with macro world properties
yeah in the real world we can touch and
see things we can touch the table we can
see you know everything except the air
okay or the table on the other side of
the planet right but uh yeah we rely on
sea and touch in our senses and so when
you say well you know the rope you can't
see or touch and they say oh what do you
mean you can't see or touch it well
hopefully like i just explained you
can't see or touch
the mediator of gravity
you know so you gotta explain
whatever you propose has to be invisible
and intangible
that's my point okay
if if it's visible or if it's tangible
you got a problem
now what we do in science we
make it visible so that you know what
we're talking about so that we can
explain the ma the mechanism it doesn't
mean that in real life you can see or
touch it it's just that we visualize it
to create our assumption with which we
are going to explain our theory okay the
explanation the mechanism
and uh no field is a concept and road is
rope is an object he says you might as
well call it a field no
these two are a different thing field is
a concept there is no physical object
called field except you know maybe a
poppy field or
you know a
football field those are different but
when we're talking about the magnetic
field or
i don't know the gravitational field
then you're not talking about anymore
you're not talking about
uh a physical object you're talking
about a concept what is a magnetic field
can you
illustrate it for me without anything
else you know don't bring the magnet or
the earth i want to see a gravitational
field all standing all by itself what
what does it look like
what does a
magnetic field look like
that's what you got to show and of
course you can't do that because it's a
mathematical concept the word field
means many numbers surrounding a number
in other words it's it's a measure of
strength
at different points in space that's how
it is around uh
ground zero
okay here's another uh file says mass
and weight are not the same
and he
points to a um
to a site you go there and all you
receive is the catechism nothing
different
who has this video has not addressed any
of the issues that i raised the other
day
and so you're welcome to look at the
video that i where i talked with about
mass and weight
and what the issues are and none of
those issues were addressed in that
video
and then he goes on he says the
calculation for work never changes for
any reason it is always work equals
force times distance
and again he shows a video it says go
there and look at it so i went there and
looked at it and the guy
only shows horizontal work
which is that first case there on the
bottom left which is force times not
distance but distance traveled okay
because he's moving a distance okay so
they're measuring that distance the
uh unrolling of the measuring tape the
front of your tape okay
but when you push something in a in in
an upward direction
then you have to
have cosine of a okay of the angle you
need the angle and you're you can be
pushing it in a straight line in an
inclined plane right
and right now you can't just use force
times distance you have to have cosine
of a you need to know that angle because
the work is different it's not the same
work to push something horizontally than
it is up an inclined plane
and this fella apparently is you know he
hasn't
gotten to high school or
college i don't know he he doesn't know
the stuff so yeah he'll he'll learn this
when he gets there
okay um and uh here's a
final comment okay last one
newtonian physics the mass of an object
does not change with speed it changes
only if we cut off or add a piece of the
object to the object correct that's
known as quantity of matter
so if you take a piece of cheese and you
add more cheese or you subtract cheese
from it then you have a different mass
okay
because you're not really moving the
object you're just adding uh
more matter to it you're adding more
atoms or subtracting atoms from it then
it has a different weight
not mass okay has a different weight
okay but yeah you by adding or
subtracting if mass is the quantity of
matter then no problem you add and you
have more mass you subtract and you have
less mass no problem there okay and
that's the notion newton had but
einstein changed that he says look as an
object moves faster its mass
increases
well einstein was talking about weight
and he called it mass because obviously
he could not uh
he he didn't understand
the nature of mass and weight
he did not understand that and again
it's very easy to here's an example you
throw an elephant
you know from the sky and falls on a on
a scale
is that scale going to measure the same
thing as if the elephant is just resting
on the scale
so what are we talking about when that
elephant is falling
well
if he moves his mass hasn't changed the
number of atoms in his body has not
changed what we're talking about is
weight we're talking about the pool of
gravity
summed up or added to
force equals mass times acceleration
okay because here we have two effects we
have the force
uh equals mass times acceleration which
is you know the force with which he's
already coming down and also the force
of gravity which is also
pulling him right
which is newton's other equation so we
have two two equations working here
okay so keep that in mind
okay with that i'm gonna
see you next time and
hopefully have a
a good weekend bye-bye we'll see you
then